[Aplausos]
antes de qualquer coisa eu vou estender
a minha mão as duas mãos para todos
vocês
e durante a minha fala eu convido vocês
a viajar nas várias histórias sobre
estende a mão a minha origem está numa
pequena cidade do interior do estado
cuja vocação sempre foi a agricultura na
época da minha primeira infância o
apelido da cidade era a terra da cebola
nem meu pai nem minha mãe tiveram muitas
oportunidades de estudo o que rendeu aos
dois déficit de condições econômicas
déficit de condições sociais e da fitch
de sonhos também por conta da grande
influência de descendentes de japoneses
na região eu fui alfabetizado primeiro
em japonês
eu cheguei o ensino fundamental falando
muito mal português o que me rendeu pela
primeira vez a incômoda sensação de ser
estrangeiro
mesmo estando no meu país mesmo assim eu
seguir com os estudos quando tinha 10
anos de idade
a minha avó materna adoeceu de maneira
bastante grave
somada com a situação bastante difícil
que os meus pais viviam na época eles
tomaram a difícil decisão de abandonar a
vida onde nós morávamos e seguir para a
cidade grande
duas eram as suas razões motivadoras a
primeira bastante óbvia eram para a
saúde da minha avó ea segunda também não
menos importante era busca por
perspectivas melhores para os filhos e
assim nós mudamos eu cheguei na cidade
grande no meio do ano letivo
você já tive que correr atrás para me
adaptar àquele ambiente era de novo
estranho e pela segunda vez
eu me senti estrangeiro novamente
mesmo assim eu seguir nos estudos
concluiu o ensino fundamental
matriculei no ensino técnico passei a
seguir no ensino técnico conclui o curso
e quando eu estava o final do curso
técnico
o responsável pela coordenação do curso
me convidou para cumprir o programa de
estágio na escola e assim foi
eu fui seguir meu programa de estágio na
própria escola que eu estudei quando
estágio estava chegando bastante no
final a responsável pelo programa me
chama e me disse assim vem cá vem aqui
falar comigo
existe uma vaga que não publiquei ainda
no portal de vagas
eu queria que você fosse ver parece uma
oportunidade legal pra você e assim eu
fui marcar em uma entrevista o
engenheiro que me atendeu simpatizou
bastante comigo bastante motivado pelo
fato de eu ser descendente de japonês e
acabei sendo contratado antes de
prosseguir essa história
algumas perguntas para todos vocês
quem se lembra do primeiro dia de aula
quem se lembra da primeira vez que
eventualmente mudou de prédio mudou de
condomínio
quem se lembra da primeira vez que fez
uma viagem internacional
quem se lembra da primeira vez que pisou
num shopping e uma praça de alimentação
todos nós aqui temos
apesar às vezes até de uma certa
dificuldade com esses eventos boas
histórias para contar
nesse primeiro dia voltando lá para o
ano de 1986 quando fui contratado
naquela empresa aquela empresa ela tinha
sido montada na capital em muito para
cuidar da expansão de uma linha de metrô
que estava em construção na cidade
e eu cheguei no meu primeiro dia de
trabalho
o primeiro dia de trabalho foi o pior
dia da minha carreira
não houve por dia amanhã naquele
primeiro dia a seguir foi apresentado
aos colegas foi apresentado o trabalho e
o dia seguiu quando o horário do almoço
foi se aproximando
aquele ambiente era completamente
estranho pra mim é a maneira como as
pessoas falavam na maneira como as
pessoas se comportavam a maneira com que
as pessoas se vestiam comparado com a
maneira que eu estava vestido é
completamente estranho e de novo eu
estava me sentindo estrangeiro se
aproximando o horário do almoço eu que
havia trânsito o almoço que minha mãe
havia preparado pra mim fui ficando cada
vez mais preocupado como eu vou fazer
a preocupação se tornou a ansiedade
ansiedade em algum momento se converteu
num profundo estresse
foi quando eu tive uma idéia no mergulho
muito dessa idéia é que eu vou contar
pra vocês mas foi a idéia que eu tive
o banheiro do escritório tinha uma
divisória de granito na entrada do
banheiro a porta abriu desse jeito havia
um canto entra no do marinheiro do lado
direito
qual foi a ideia vou pegar embalagem do
meu almoço vou me sentar naquele
cantinho e vão alimentar o mais rápido
que puder
mesmo dando conta que tinha esquecido os
talheres na mochila eu continuei comendo
mais rápido que pude e torcendo um
para que ninguém descobrisse o problema
é que me descobriram um colega que não
costumava almoçar entrou no banheiro
virou pelo lado direito olhou para baixo
e me viu ali naqueles 23 segundos que os
nossos olhares se cruzaram uma mistura
de sensações me invadiu medo terror um
profundo sentimento de incompetência e
pior de impotência que me pôs paralisado
ali sentado no chão com embalagem do meu
almoço nos braços
esse meu colega não pensou duas vezes e
estendeu a mão e colocou de pé me deu um
abraço e falou vai ficar tudo bem vamos
sair logo daqui pra ninguém te vê me
levou pra fora do banheiro não levou até
o refeitório aqueceu a minha comida
conseguiu talhares emprestado pra mim
mais previsivelmente havia cumprir
perdido completamente à fome
esse evento aconteceu há 33 anos atrás
refletindo na sensação de solidão e
desamparo que eu senti naquele momento
eu fico me perguntando se essa sensação
não é semelhante à de um refugiado de um
escrito social mas ainda mais próxima a
mente de todos nós
um jovem que vive na periferia de
grandes cidades como essa aqui
e que por exemplo nunca foi ao cinema
olhando pra 1987 quando os meus pais por
conta da doença da minha vó se mudaram
para a cidade grande
existem várias razões e porque as
pessoas se movem pelo mundo por exemplo
venezuelanos que fogem da grave situação
econômica e política do país
sírios que fogem da guerra haitianos e
moçambicanos que fogem das graves
consequências de terremoto por exemplo
mais próximo a mente de todos nós
pessoas por exemplo que estão no
ambiente como esse oprimidos por
professores a dura realidade de estudo e
hodgins amparo que visita a essas
pessoas
por exemplo os gestores extremamente
duros extremamente opressores com as
quais aquele medo de perder o emprego
motivo as pessoas aí aguentando
aguentando aguentando e seguem no dia a
dia
a minha reflexão sobre isso
existem várias formas de entender isso
que acabam desencadeando os fenômenos de
ansiedade ou a doença que parece ser o
mal do século 21 que a depressão mas há
um grande problema que na minha opinião
é a falta de conexão
a falta de conexão de encadeada por um
gesto simples muito simples
voltando para trás novamente para aquela
estranhíssimo alinha no currículo que eu
tenho de ter tentado a moça no banheiro
15 anos se passaram a gente chega no ano
de 2001
várias atividades foram incorporados à
minha carreira entre elas eu havia me
tornado estrutura interna de treinamento
eu estou aplicando o módulo qual é a
minha surpresa quando eu olho pro fundo
da sala e ele não instalar
foi um momento de extrema alegria pra
mim
terminou o módulo fui procurá-lo dei um
abraço nele
foi um momento de absoluta celebração e
claro não podia deixar de passar a
oportunidade de agradecer por terem
salvo no banheiro esquisitíssimo foi a
reação dele eu não lembro de jeito
nenhum disse que também contando
banheiro
fui eu mesmo que fiz isso
se eu fiz isso e não me lembro
pode ser que não foi grande coisa talvez
por isso eu me lembre não se passaram
dois anos exatamente decidir
chegamos ao ano de 2003 uma segunda
feira chegou no escritório em torno de
20 para 18 uma pequena confusão está
acontecendo em torno da mesa da
secretária
eu vou até lá pergunta para ela o que
havia acontecido e ela me disse assim
sabe o que é esse meu amigo do banheiro
ele passou mal na frente da estação de
trem aqui próximo o chefe dele já correu
lá parece que não está bem e o chefe
dele está pedindo para mais alguém lá
pra tomar notícias para começar a vida a
família
eu me ofereci para aí peguei meu carro
fui lá só que quando eu cheguei lá o
carro de ambulância já estava indo
embora
como já era inútil fica lá retornou
escritório não se passaram 40 minutos
nós recebemos a terrível notícia
que ele não havia suportado a parada
cardiorrespiratória e havia chegado sem
vida ao hospital
uma sensação de vazio
talvez também muito motivado por ter
sido ele me invadiu novamente que era
extremamente parecida com aquela
sensação paralisante que eu sentir
naquele banheiro
voltando exatamente o dia do banheiro no
ano de 1986
vou mandar um ano a gente chega em 1987
eu já havia apreendido várias coisas já
tinha evoluído em termos de conhecimento
profissional eu estava trabalhando em
uma linha que estava em expansão na
capital fazendo testes e parte da minha
actividade obrigava a fazer vários
testes de madrugada foram entre 14 e 16
noites seguidas eu parecia um zumbi
porque era praticamente todo dia fazendo
esses testes nesses testes havia uma
pessoa um profissional que era
referência em sistemas de controle de
trens que ao longo desse período de
testes também estava trabalhando nessa
mesma operação que eu
o objetivo dessa operação era a forma
como a estação era intermediário na
linha
normalmente o retorno do treino é feito
pelas duas plataformas ea operação
significa automatizar o sistema para que
as duas plataformas pudessem prestar
serviço passou os testes foram testes
bastante difíceis e na madrugada de
domingo para segunda feira nós
entregamos o sistema procurador
e nós que havíamos terminado o trabalho
de madrugada
nós também erramos retornar para casa de
metrô
nós nos sentamos no banco da estação
center e eu aqui esse meu colega aqui e
uma senhora sem todo lado
mas aos 34 minutos o primeiro trem
chegou abriu as portas
eu eo meu colega nos levantamos na
direção do trem e essa senhora
interpelando o meu colega disse assim
mas é estranho também vai para o oeste
sim senhora meu colega explicou a partir
de hoje essa estação essa plataforma
também vai prestar serviço no meio é
sabidamente desconfiada entrou no trem
conosco até ter pensado em ser bom se
eles que trabalham muito entrar no trem
eu também vou entrar e entrou no trem
conosco quando a porta fechou o treino
começou a se movimentar
ela cutucou o meu colega na verdade o
movimento foi porque eu estou do lado e
falou assim pra ele 'você sabe que horas
eu vou chegar e vou chegar a 20 minutos
antes e fui tomar café mas se todo dia
desse jeito todo dia vou poder tomar
café
aí ele disse sim agora todo dia 3 vai
prestar esse serviço
ela ficou super a a assim animada ela se
levantou dentro do trem tem deus nos
puxa muito obrigado por vocês terem
feito isso e ele tem três por que não
nós prestamos serviço do metrô nós não
somos o metrô
mas enfim passou a hyatt chega no ano de
2007 exatamente esse meu colega
ele me disse assim lembra que o evento
que aconteceu na estação do metrô
aquilo ali é um bom motivo pra você
explicar os seus pais o que você faz
você não sempre comenta que é difícil
porque os seus pais você faz ou fez isso
porque o meu pai minha mãe mas foi
inútil explicar
tava muito abstrato não deu pra entender
e aí um ano depois ele me indicou para
um projeto bastante crítico no treme
procurou fizemos uma reunião de trabalho
ele me disse assim tem que ser você
por que você é o mestre você conhece
toda a evolução do sistema você tem que
trabalhar neste projecto é um projecto
de renovação em troca de equipamento por
bolinha que estava em expansão no estado
da califórnia nos estados unidos
eu disse pra ele escuta o conceito mais
importante que eu sei na minha profissão
foi você quem me ensinou
aí ele falou assim que leva não fala
muita bobagem não leva a sério
sete anos se passaram
a gente chega no ano de 2014 ele entrou
numa briga severa com câncer
ele ficou afastado vários meses chegou a
afastar ficar afastado perto de um ano e
um dia no condomínio onde nós
trabalhávamos estou caminhando pro
almoço eu cruzo com ele foi muito legal
muito positiva encontrar novamente ele
me disse assim voltei a fumar porque se
volta a falar porque não tem mais jeito
e voltei a fumar antes de ir embora ele
me disse assim eu quero te agradecer por
tudo que você fez por você ter passado
por todos os momentos na carreira e você
se ter tornado o profissional que você
se tornou mais um ano depois ele veio a
falecer
passou um tempo eu comecei a trabalhar
no projecto bastante crítico onde uma
grande evolução foi feita onde o sistema
de frenagem sistema de aceleração do
trem foi afetada e em um dos finais de
semana eu vou na casa dos meus pais e
minha mãe disse assim eu acho que
entendi o que você faz porque o 30
frendo mais macio acelerando mais macio
eu não caio mais dentro do carro
acho que entendi finalmente o que você
faz
minha mãe desta vez ela me deu uma lição
de que a engenharia pode ser gentil
o que eu quero deixar aqui pra vocês
estender a mão e ser grato pelas pessoas
é um movimento que torna as conexões
possíveis no micro
tenta se lembrar de alguém que fez algo
importante por você é muito importante
talvez essa pessoa nem lembre do que
tenha feito hoje
hoje exatamente por isso eu é que
estendo a mão pra todos vocês muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]